on va commencer avec la première partie
qui concerne l'observation et la mémoire
la observations l'observation est noir
voici la première question d'observation
et mémoire cette image est la
combinaison de deux personnalités
célèbres lesquels 15 secondes
voici l'image c'est parti voici l'image
s'il vous plaît l'image est ce que c'est
frédéric lopez plus laurence ferrari
stéphane plaza puis sophie davant
patrick sébastien plus calibré novelli
ou gilles verdez plus brigitte macron
allez vous avez plus que 10 secondes et
vous répondez également chez vous savez
partie vraiment d'un test de cuisse est
incertain est d'observation
ciao ça y est vous avez alors vous avez
tous répondu qu'est ce que vous avez
répondu isabelle morini-bosc stéphane
plaza sophie la vente de qualité novelli
n'a de pareilles quelques a répondu
autre chose non vous avez tous acquis la
bonne répondu quoi vous 4 gilles verdez
[Applaudissements]
les cheveux voilà là on pas appel à
votre flexibilité mentale je vous dis
oui
en fait c'est la capacité de réfléchir à
plusieurs possibilités tout les
problèmes voilà et bat pour l'instant
mon cas que des bonnes réponses sauf doc
gynéco vous démarré sur les chapeaux
vraiment grave on croit qu'il va être
long le prime pour d'autres à wingles et
la balance son poste derrière le préfet
de balances ton poste d'arrière à les
[Rires]
attentions deuxième question chez vous
vous également sur cette image
retrouvez le morceau the créole mokolo
attention regardez l'image alors à deux
trois ou quatre on voit maxime guinea
avec bernard montiel retrouver le
morceau de puzzle marquant sur cette
image est ce que c'est le 1 le 2 le 3 ou
le 4
ok
un deux trois ou quatre alors vous avez
dit quoi matthieu delormeau la bonne
réponse c'est milo ouais je vous donne
la bonne réponse dans un instant vous
avez mis quoi jean michel maire se
planter un 2003 lol également qu' ami
autre chose que le 1 à part jean michel
donc jean-michel vous êtes le seul à
vous êtes trompés et oui vous démarrez
très bien aussi c'est bien sûr le un sas
est question sollicite la rotation
mentale
alors j'ai beaucoup de rotations fema
réaliser un témoin oui voilà
et là je suis vert vous voilà un ballon
rond face à l'animal merci alors quand
on peut il pas utiliser nos mains le
cerveau se représente mentalement
l'association a réalisé voilà donc pour
l'instant est ça se passe bien
as tu en voilà par jean-michel et dope
fait une erreur chacun pour l'instant
les doutes il n'y a aucune erreur ça
commence gentiment
voici la 3d d'un rom attention soyez
attentifs et faites appel à votre
mémoire la chrono voilà vous avez vu la
combinaison est ce que vous l'avez
retenue non mais parce que c'est rouge
vert jaune jaune rouge bleu
oh là là où je vert jaune rouge jaune
bleu rouge vert jaune bleu jodoin qui
sert au rouge vert jaune et quatre
jeunes bleus
les creux dit redit rouge vert jaune
jaune rouge bleu
non mais les mecs se foutait de ma
gueule ou quoi
bah voilà passé comme ça rouge vert
jaune rouge jaune bleu vd vite vite vit
du rsa que ce contrat allait encore bébé
est pêché vous dépêchez vous s'il vous
plaît dépêchez vous
racing où là il y a alors qu'est ce que
vous avez dit matthieu delormeau la
bonne réponse pour le prime time de quoi
à 3 lacroix non alors que jamais dit
quoi vous d'origine et court trois
croient donc guinée comme matthieu
delormeau ensemble géraldine des rois
mages et 10,2 vous avez dit latvala
devant jean-michel mais on n'est pas
réglée m 2 mais je ne savais pas répondu
malheureusement que j'avais donné prêté
dans les délais légalement la bonne
réponse c'est rouge vert jaune rouge
jaune bleu de matthieu delormeau et doc
gynéco donc j'ai des cours fait un
départ en fanfare la question deux
erreurs c'est à isabelle vous êtes
trompés également oui vous savez quoi
mais gênés 3 j'étais persuadé que
c'était le vert-jaune-bleu bas mais tout
le monde a été passionné ça s'appelle ça
c'est ça c'est la question sur les sites
la mémoire à court terme les mémoriser
les trois premiers et derniers à
l'effort un trait mais je vous dis va
être très fort une catastrophe un jérémy
ray sur vous a fini je bifurque je me
sur casse tête
j'espère que vous faites le test qu'elle
peut le faire sur twitter également
élevé également sur facebook qui a les
mêmes photocopier on va vous imaginez
vous êtes une sort dans 2 minutes non
mais c'est repos elle fait attention la
question quatre questions d'observation
encore observez bien la photo de rentrer
les chroniqueurs de tpm pique mon dieu a
été un peu regardez bien cette photo
regardez bien cette photo
regardez bien chez vous également
c'est bon ouais vous avez observé
pendant 10 secondes
vous allez maintenant observer cette
deuxième faute attention question 1
qu'est ce qui a changé entre les deux
voici les possibilités les motifs de la
robe de valérie ont changé au [ __ ] de
chroniqueurs ont interverti leurs places
un chroniqueur a disparu dans ça c'est
vrai dans l'émission ou maxime enfin pu
choquer ni me par an voir la photo et
d'inigo d' attaque à cinq ça fait partie
du sel non souple et ça fait partie du
test
alors je vous le dit jean michel a bien
répondu vous ai dit quoi deux
conducteurs internet c'était nabila et
géraldine maillet qui ont interverti
revoir les photos si vous voulez
regarder chez vous regardez regardez
chez vous si vous devez pas vous voilà
donc regarder vous voyez vous regardez
bien nabila cayla et géraldine allemagne
et qui échoue c'est flou est là et
regarder la deuxième photo op
elles ont interverti leurs places
benjamin castaldi vous avez encore la
bonne réponse mais aussi un valérie
bénaïm également les autres trop tard et
gilles vous avez dit quoi ça s'est
trompé un chroniqueur qui avait disparu
et maxime vous avez de l'amour aux aussi
un chroniqueur qui avait disparu eh ben
vous êtes dans le faux le faut on fera
un petit point dans un instant cinquième
question cinquième question
attention 15 secondes encore pour
répondre vous rappelle ses quinze
secondes l'échelle dessin n'est pas
comme les autres au point un test de
culte où ça fait parti d'un test depuis
très très sérieux quel dessein n'est pas
comme les autres doc gynéco me regarde
il me fait très peur j'ai dit deux mois
[Musique]
au [ __ ] dont il est comme le dit quoi
2 alors maintenant
donc on sait que deux n'est pas la bonne
réponse alors bonjour vous le dire ah
oui la bonne réponse
tout le monde à fond ah bon si si
puisque quel dessein n'est pas comme les
autres c'est le 3 et wii c'est le 3
regardez regardez bien regardez bien
puisque là mais non c'est le 2e de ses
lots 2 alors je vous le dis parce qu'ils
ont interverti sur mes filles j'avais
jeu je dis que c'est le 2 et le 3 e 3 eh
bien le 2 mai voilà bien le 2 il y avait
une erreur sur ma famille et amis
lisbonne et vous avez déclaré le 2 2 le
2 donc les cherry est ce qu'on pouvait
comptabiliser la bonne réponse en régie
agathe hard c'est bon oui vous n'avez
pas répondu dans les temps je jure sur
ma life non non je ne dirais pas sinon
je dirai pas si donc vraiment ça c'est
pas afficher annoncé maintenant c'est
bon c'est bon on me dit en régie que
tout cette affiche est malheureusement
matthieu delormeau
c'est pas parce que vous avez fait ouf
attendez pas non plus à des miracles
déjà qu'on soit déjà 50% doit répondre
on sera tous très contents donc tout le
monde a bien répondu non et bravo si je
sais pas vous étiez en rouge on va
comptabiliser tension sixième question
quel symbole ne figure pas dans le
tableau vous allez d'abord mémoriser un
tableau pendant 10 secondes vaches
allez-y vous mémoriser ce tableau
pendant 10 secondes
alors c'est terminé chez vous également
je vous pose la question quel symbole ne
figure pas dans le tableau avions
voitures lunettes punaises
ok je le lève et me copient pas mamie a
fini vite vite kelly brook et maxime
gainey dépêchez vous mais pas répondu
kelly medvedi c'est bon et bien qu est
ce que vous avez dit doc gynéco je pense
que ces trois mais j'ai dit 4 vous avez
dit il avait des punaises donc on a des
jeunes répondent ses dernières actions
posées on va revoir le temps mauvais
temps les chéris regarder le tableau
ensemble ça a été bien sûr il y à bien
un avion oui il ya bien une punaise mais
bien débuté mais il n'y a pas de
voitures camions exactement il n'a pas
de voiture
il n'y a que des bonnes réponses sur doc
gynéco une aise
c'est fort comment vous sentez pour
l'instant benhaim et castaldi très fort
dit ben ali mais castaldi gimont stress
mois ah ouais mais non benhaim on voit
que c'était la première la classe dans
les vallées benhaim est vrai que ça avec
les trucs de mathématiques tout ça je
suis nul mais on sait on si les avances
attention question 7 pour cette question
je vous montre une vidéo me concerne et
ensuite j'ai posé trois questions au
regard des biens la vidéo
la base est la question le numéro de
benjamin terrain finit par 16 61 26
pouces 56 et tour après je peux pas
l'appeler 16 61 et vous avez un avantage
cet avantage khaled réponse est oui ça
m'est donc c'est pas mal mais si mal oui
mes copies passe avant jusqu'aux pippa
trois garçons ça va tu sais pas alors
numéro de benjamin castaldi finit par 16
61 26 56 vous avez dit quoi 16h16 et
bien moi j'aurais castaldi a commis une
erreur puisque son numéro sur la fiche
termine par 56 oui regardez on peut
regarder l'affiché ou paix juste la
fiche wii et wii et wii donc c'est pas
le bon numéro de benjamin maintenant
vous savez le bon alors je vous le dis
il y à kelly vdev dit qu'elle me
répondit géraldine mathieu isabelle
gillet vous a répondu quoi déjà mais
j'avais 10 16
bob a forcément c'est la mauvaise
réponse un bien entendu pour l'instant
je vous dis pas mal élevés novelli pas
mal aussi un pas mal du tout pour
l'instant je vous le dis le dernier
c'est doc gynéco secours l'instant et je
vous lis pour l'instance le prends la
première nommée sinndar cas je vous lis
pour l'instant la première c'est magali
berda
[Applaudissements]
alors je rappelle que le gagnant gagnera
en prime time et là c'est surtout une
thalheim et magali berda est première
avec les bonnes réponses sur neuf en
l'absence de mathieu un jour magali
berda bravo à vous il y à une deuxième
ex-aequo il ya le premier ex-aequo c'est
daniel murugan ans mais bien sûr qu'on a
peu changé il ya encore énormément
nation je vous le rappelle alors
exactement un beau prime gestion vis ça
très beau prime de noël est une belle
affiche
oui combien de face le solide suivent
orco tilt je googler de passe combien de
face le solide suivant compte il est
pêché voire 10 11 12 ou 16 go jouer chez
vous également 10 11 12 ou 16 c'est la
première partie du test de qi alors
combien de face le solide suivant
ont-ils rien 10 11 12 ou 16 sabawi pas
parce que tu as triste garder sûrement
normal c'est l'âge
bah oui bon c'est mathématique alors ok
je sais que chez vous je vois sur
twitter vous êtes comme des fous grand
ouest lâché qu'il extrêmement sérieux on
vous donnera les vrais résultats à la
fin
combien vous avez dit rick gynéco pour
qu'on ait déjà la mauvaise réponse douze
noms et voilà ça n'est pas la bonne a
dévissé il faut bien compter toutes les
faces coupable d'ailleurs toutes celles
qui forment la zone découpé en son
milieu
et ne pas oublier d'ajouter le dessus et
le dessous la réponse est donc regarder
parce qu en fait voilà c'est pas vrai 2
3 5 6 7 8 9 voilà après vous mêmes de
l'intérieur avait dû parallélépipède
cela j ai intégré
à la forme ni des rampes à cette forme
géométrique
bien sûr le parallélépipède il ne
fallait pas l'oublier jean michel
vernhes n'ai pas répondu isabelle morini
bosc
donc il est 16 non merci j'ai failli
faire polytechnique et libido béni c'est
faux et notre championne
notre championne daniel moreau daniel
moreau daniel moign encore la bonne
réponse de daniel mermet ciel tu es
magnifique tu est bouclé pour l'instant
et priant je vais vous donner le
classement à la fin de cette 1ère cat
hambourg à ce que vous avez trouvé cette
première catégorie difficile
des questions restent encore
trois-quatre jours il sera demain soir
là ouais ça montre que je vis ça monte
et était un peu déconcentré par rapport
à mon portable mais c'était pas grave
c'est parce que vous étiez trop fort on
a voulu vous maîtrisez alors je vous le
dis on va voir tout de suite les
statistiques je vous dis
pour l'instant en dernier lieu c'est doc
gynéco pas avec trois bonnes réponses
younès vous êtes dernier vous pouvez
largement vous rattrapera ensuite on a
une égalité avec matthieu delormeau
pardon benoît et vous êtes à égalité
benoît dubois
[Rires]
de là vous dire il ya il a quatre
égalités en plus après avec matthieu
delormeau benoît dubois
isabelle et jean michel baylet 2 salles
d'aude voilà ensuite à voile à 50% de
bons résultats puisque doc gynéco à 30%
de bons résultats ensuite à 60% de bons
résultats on a un groupe composé de
gilles verdez de maxime de khédive et
novelli voilà c'est pas mal vous vous en
sortez mais cette forme s'est pas ou
courriel là on commence à rentrer dans
les bons et yang avec 70% de bonnes
réponses
valérie bénaïm christine kelly géraldine
maillet et benjamin castaldi no et
ensuite
et ensuite on a les cadors les cadors
pour cette première partie daniel moreau
et magali verda avec 90 de son fier de
nous je sers l'arrière dans son livre
est encore c'est qu'il était très bonne